[Music]  bachelor nation we knew it was coming  but now we know how it all went down  Rachel Lindsey is of course our new  bachelorette and Monday night we saw how  she left The Bachelor and that's really  [Music]  Rachel I'm sorry take him on it say  goodbye yes Nick vile sent Rachel home  even after telling her how much he cared  Rachel I am falling for you one percent  mm-hmm  you know like it's easy to say and this  was hard to watch Rachel sadly seemed  very confident in a relationship I'm  falling in love of you at this point I  am so all-in  I feel confident I'm looking forward to  what's next you know after the rose  because you know I know that I'll get to  meet his family as she went home mascara  filled tears streaked down her beautiful  face don't worry Rachel we cannot wait  to watch you as the Bachelorette what  did you guys think of Rachel's exit were  you surprised by the way that Nick sent  her home let me know over on Twitter  you